my invitation is open come
join me on the island
[Music]
wow that's your new lead another monster
hunt
elizabeth megafig is a two-bit con
artist
don't tell me you actually believe this
half-baked nonsense
i swear if you chase this bug snack
story
you're out of a job you're the
journalist
desperate said you'd be coming there's a
bug snack
right over there do me a favor and take
my snack trap
stranger i could use your help this
bunger goes wild for ketchup
we'll use it to lead the bunger over
yonder
i want you to use that journalistic
instinct to find out what my
favorite bug snack is and feed it to me
ops how's my little sprout doing he
misses papa
no of course he does well i have a few
prototype traps that i could put to use
you're pretty good at stuff and nobody
hates you yet
you can catch bug snacks and bring
everybody back to snacksburg
[Music]
well say you do find these bug snacks
and make it back alive
you just might keep your job now get
going and try not to fall off a cliff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you